[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZAK STONE: Welcome to
"Cloud OnAir," live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
like this every Tuesday.
I'm Zak Stone and
I'm here to talk
to you about supercomputers
for machine learning
called Cloud TPUs.
You can ask questions at
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
Here's a sneak peek
at three generations
of our Tensor
Processing Unit systems,
or TPUs, that we're going
to be talking about today.
But before we get
into the details,
I'd just like to set a
little bit of context
about the tremendous
amount of progress
in machine learning there's been
over the past several years,
to explain why these
TPUs are so useful.
There's a website called Archive
where people are publishing
papers in machine
learning out in the open,
and what you can see here is
a plot of the number of papers
published over time.
The amazing thing is, this
rate is tracking faster
than Moore's law, and we're
now up to more than 50 machine
learning papers
published every day.
There's a tremendous amount
of activity in the field.
And among those
many papers, there
have been tremendous
improvements in accuracy
on standard benchmarks such
as the ImageNet recognition
competition.
You can see here off to the
left, the AlexNet paper that
was the first one to apply
these deep convolutional neural
networks with GPUs to
the ImageNet challenge.
And then since then, there's
been tremendous innovation,
both in the network
architectures, the systems
to train these
models, all the way up
and to the right here in 2017.
And we've even exceeded
these accuracies now.
But this isn't just
about benchmarks
for scientific computing.
These new deep learning
models have also
brought about breakthroughs
in real world applications,
such as you can see here
in diabetic retinopathy.
So researchers at the medical
brain team here at Google
have been trying to diagnose
a leading cause of blindness
from taking these images
of the back of the eye.
And they discovered
in the process
of doing so that
you can also get
early indications
of heart disease
in this entirely passive way.
This wasn't previously known.
And this is just
one small indication
of how these machine
learning models
are opening up new applications
in medicine and elsewhere
that are really going to
improve people's lives.
Similarly, here, folks have
been repurposing old cell phones
as listening devices
in the rain forest
to help catch signs of illegal
logging in the central Amazon.
So these applications are just
a sample of many, many new ways
that machine learning
can be applied now
that we're reaching these
high level of accuracies
across many different
domains ranging
from image recognition
to speech recognition
to machine translation and more.
And one thing that I
found especially exciting
is that the same kinds of
mathematical techniques
are now used to achieve
state of the art results
across these many
different disciplines.
When I was in grad school
in computer vision,
the techniques that we
used in computer vision
didn't relate at all
to the techniques that
were being used for state of
the art speech recognition
at the time, or state of
the art machine translation.
Now, even though the models
aren't necessarily the same,
we're finding that they're built
of the same building blocks--
the dense linear algebra,
the matrix multiplies,
and vector operations that have
been put together in this field
called deep learning.
And so what that
means is you can
use some of the same tools and
the same hardware platforms
to solve many
different problems.
However, there is a challenge.
As you can see here, going back
to that case study of image
recognition accuracy
improving over time,
as you're getting to higher
and higher levels of accuracy,
you're also requiring
more and more computation.
In this case, on
the x-axis, you're
seeing the number of
multiply add operations,
which is sort of a rough
measure of complexity
of the amount of
compute required
to run one of these models.
But that also corresponds
to the amount of compute
that you're required
to train the model.
And so we're continuing to
move up and to the right,
but we're requiring more
computation to do it,
both to train the model
and then to run that model
and make it useful.
So how do we address
this challenge?
Well, we believe that the
answer is specialized hardware
for machine learning, such as
these tensor processing units.
Here's a brief tour of the
history of TPUs at Google.
This is the first
one that we built
that's been deployed in
data center since 2015
this one is focused
on inference,
and you interacted
with one of these
whenever you ran a search.
It would be used to re-rank the
last several hundred results
to choose those 10 blue links
that you get every time you
search on Google.
It was used in Street
View, in Google Photos,
in speech recognition,
and across a wide variety
of applications that you
interact with every day.
But that wasn't enough.
We moved on after that to
the second generation tensor
processing unit, which was
built into these whole systems.
Here, you can see a device that
we call the Cloud TPU that you
can rent today on Google Cloud.
It's in beta, there's
no waiting, no sign up.
You just follow the link
g.co/cloudtpu and fire up
a Cloud TPU, following
our quickstart.
But these devices aren't
just standalone the way
the first TPU was.
They're actually designed
to be connected together
into these giant
supercomputers called TPU pods.
And these will be coming
to Cloud later this year,
both in the larger
configurations
and in smaller slices that
you can use on demand.
And the nice thing
about the TPU pod
is you can apply even more
computation to a single machine
learning problem to train
a model to the accuracy
that you desire faster.
That helps you really
improve your iteration time.
Because training a model is
sort of like compiling code
in the world that
you're used to,
of programming line by line.
You have to do it
over and over again
to develop a good application.
And at Google I/O, we
revealed that we're not just
stopping at TPUv2.
We have a TPUv3, which
is a whole new chip built
into these whole
new systems that
are even larger
and more powerful
than the TPUv2 device and pod.
So just to give you a
quantitative sense of how
fast this field is
moving and the lengths
we're going to to achieve
even greater amounts
of machine learning
performance, you
can see that TPUv1 was
able to do 92 teraops,
whereas cloud TPU took
that to 180 teraflops
with 64 gigabytes of high
bandwidth memory per board,
going from inference only
in the first generation
to supporting
training and inference
in the second generation.
You stitch all those
together and you
can do even more than
11 and 1/2 petaflops
with 4 terabytes of HBM.
And now the third
generation pod breaks
the barrier of 100 petaflops.
More than 8x the
performance of a TPUv2
pod through both a new chip
and this larger scale system.
So we're really committed
to expanding the AI frontier
and to sharing our
hardware platforms
and the software we run on
top of them, like TensorFlow,
with all of you
through Google Cloud.
So I'd like to
focus on real world
performance with the Cloud
TPUs that you can rent today.
Now, I know that one thing,
if you're training machine
learning models or running
machine learning models,
performance is one of the most
important features for you.
And I just want to emphasize
how important it is to measure
performance carefully.
We try to emphasize
performance measurements that
are involving real
data, where you
have a real model
that's training
to a specific accuracy.
And then you're measuring the
complete time to accuracy,
or cost to accuracy.
If you read about performance
out on the internet,
you might see people talking
about images per second
or steps per second.
And that's important,
but it's not useful
if you're just measuring
that in isolation,
because it's really
important to make sure
that the model that
you're measuring
that's processing, let's say,
lots of images per second,
will actually get to the
destination you want to go,
which is a specific accuracy on
a specific benchmark data set.
So whenever you're
looking at benchmarks,
we really encourage you to look
for real world data, not just
synthetic data, for
time to accuracy,
and also look for
total cost, especially
via public clouds, where
it's easy to do these apples
to apples comparisons.
We've also put a lot of emphasis
on making our machine learning
benchmarks reproducible
via open source,
so you don't just have
to believe the numbers
that I'm sharing today.
You can run our open source
code on Cloud TPUs and measure
results yourself, either
on standard benchmarks
or then on your own data.
One benchmark
competition that we
think was especially well
designed was from Stanford.
It's called DAWNBench,
and there's a URL here.
This competition
recently concluded.
And they looked at a
variety of data sets,
including the standard
ImageNet benchmark
for image recognition.
And they measured both
training time and total cost.
And they also had other
competitions for inference.
And we think that these
metrics were really
getting at the kinds of things
that you, as practitioners,
care about in your
day to day work.
I'm happy to announce that we
had the number one DAWNBench
entry for ImageNet
training cost.
And we achieved that with
this AmoebaNet-D model.
And the interesting
thing about AmoebaNet-D
is the architecture was
actually built on a TPU
through an evolutionary
process automatically.
So instead of
designing this model
by hand with countless
grad student hours,
the way most of those models
that I referenced earlier
have been designed, we
ran a search process,
measuring a population
of models and choosing
the ones that performed best
on similar image recognition
tasks.
Then we've open sourced
that final winning model,
AmoebaNet-D and you can run
it yourself on the Cloud TPU
platform today.
Turns out, it trains to the
target accuracy of 93% top five
on ImageNet in just
7 and 1/2 hours,
for under $50,
which we think makes
these kinds of state of the art
machine learning results much
more affordable for everybody.
There's also a model
called ResNet-50
that's often used as a benchmark
to compare different systems,
one to the other.
And so I should
just mention here
that our ResNet-50
implementation, which is also
open source, is able to
deliver 3,250 images a second
with real data, which
is really exciting,
and train to the similar
final accuracy of 93%,
top five, which is not easy to
achieve with a ResNet-50 model.
That happens in
8.9 hours for $60.
And if you want
to go even faster,
this is the advantage of
being able to scale up
into these pods.
Here, you can see our
number one DAWNBench
entry with half of
a TPU pod, where
we were able to train
in just 30 minutes.
And actually, if you eliminate
the overhead of checkpointing
to measure your
accuracy at every step,
the minimum time is just 23.9
minutes to get to that same 93%
accuracy target.
So I'm really excited
about the fact
that you can develop on
one of these Cloud TPUs
and then soon, you'll be able to
scale up with no code changes,
just changing your batch size,
onto larger and larger slices
of these TPU pods.
Now, I mentioned earlier
the number of archive papers
that are getting
published every day,
and there is real
progress happening there,
including new tricks that
sometimes change the algorithms
and make it possible to
achieve your goals even faster.
One set of those tricks
came from an organization
called fast.ai, which published
a very strong third place entry
in the DAWNBench competition.
They showed that if you
progressively scale up
the size of your training
images while you're training,
that can let you go even
faster in the early stages
of your training process.
And they also came up with
a different, more aggressive
learning rate schedule that
wasn't widely known that
had been published previously.
And they put these
together, and they
were able to train
the ResNet-50 model,
with this modified
training protocol,
to 93% accuracy much faster.
Fortunately, because all this
is happening out in the open,
we were able to reproduce these
algorithmic changes quickly
on Cloud TPU after the DAWNBench
competition had closed,
and that takes our training
costs down from $59
to just $25, even at
on-demand pricing.
So we think it's
really fantastic
that so many people are
out there experimenting
with different things
and that they're
sharing their
results in the open
so that you can benefit from
them immediately on Cloud
TPUs or other platforms.
Now, you might
wonder, well, what's
the next benchmark challenge,
now that DAWNBench is over?
We recommend MLPerf, which
you can find at MLPerf.org.
There's a number
of organizations
that are coming
together to define
an even newer and more
challenging and diverse
set of benchmarks.
And so this has been
announced recently,
and there will be
deadlines later this year.
If you want to submit
your own entries,
I'd highly encourage
you to do so.
So as I mentioned before, if
you want to experience the kind
of performance I'm talking
about today on these Cloud TPU
devices, 180 teraflops,
you can do so by visiting--
the simplest link
is g.co/cloudtpu,
but you can also follow
these other two links to see
our documentation, where
we have tutorials for many
of the models that I'll mention,
or you can just go straight
to GitHub and read the code
yourself for some of the state
of the art models that I
mentioned earlier today.
Now, what's it like to
actually use these Cloud TPUs?
I want to give you more of a
sense of how these things work
and what it's like
to work with them.
So one important point
is that Cloud TPUs
are network-attached.
So this is different
from other accelerators.
You can choose a VM of whatever
size or shape that you want,
which I'm showing here
in the middle here.
The customer off to the
left is SSHed into that VM,
you can install whatever
software you want,
you can attach other
accelerators if you want to,
you can choose a
custom size and shape.
And then you install our
machine image that we provide,
which has open source TensorFlow
on it, with TensorFlow 1.8,
and then this VM communicates
over the network with a Cloud
TPU.
Now, this does add one
layer of interaction,
but we still try to provide
maximum flexibility and control
with this Cloud
TPU infrastructure.
And the nice thing about
this network separation
is that Cloud TPU can either
be a single device, like I
was showing you
earlier, or it could
be a whole slice of a pod.
You don't have to
worry about it.
There are no drivers to install.
And you can use your
VM, which can be small,
to drive this
enormous supercomputer
to get your training jobs
done quickly and efficiently.
Now, as I've
mentioned throughout,
these Cloud TPUs today are
programmed with TensorFlow.
And I'd recommend
using TensorFlow 1.8
to get our greatest
optimizations
and the maximum
performance that we're
able to deliver on Cloud TPUs.
Now, TensorFlow is a really
practical and popular tool kit.
Ever since being open
sourced in November, 2015,
it's just really taken off.
If you look at
these GitHub stars,
they're just up
and to the right.
I think this is now within the
top five most popular projects
on GitHub overall.
And we've seen more than 13
million downloads of TensorFlow
all around the world.
So this is really a
production ready framework
that's used in everything
from research labs
to applications that
you interact with that
have billions of users.
Now, TensorFlow has
a whole ecosystem,
and I'm going to focus
today on the TF data API,
on layers, estimators,
and XLA, because those
are the components that you use
to program these Cloud TPUs.
So estimators and layers
are these high level,
deep learning abstractions for
TensorFlow that you don't just
have to use on TPUs.
You can use them on
other platforms as well.
And we're trying to make it
easy for you to shift code
back and forth from one
platform to another,
so you're not locked in.
Now, here's an example
of the kind of model
you might write with
layers and estimators.
This is a convolutional model.
And so you can run this
on your local computer.
And how do you change it to
make it compatible with a TPU?
Well, in this case, you
just have some small changes
to make.
You wrap the optimizer
here, as you can see,
and then you're using
a TPU estimator.
And we're working to minimize
these changes over time.
Now, one thing I
want to say, though,
is that high
performance computing
is challenging on any platform.
And so we've put a lot
of effort into building
a set of reference models
that are open source
that you can just use right away
as starting points so you don't
have to do this performance
optimization from scratch
yourself in these many
different application domains.
So to give you a sense of the
reference models, a snapshot
that we have today, we've got
the kinds of image recognition
models that I've already
discussed off to the left,
including the state of
the art AmoebaNet model.
We've also got various sides of
ResNets and inception models,
of V2, V3, and V4.
But we've also got
object detection
with RetinaNet,
that helps you find
multiple objects in an image.
We've got low resource
models like MobileNet,
if you want to then deploy
your model out at the edge,
on a phone or a vehicle
or some other device.
But these TPUs aren't just
limited to image recognition
and object detection.
They're also useful for
machine translation or language
modeling, or even sentiment
analysis or question answering.
I'll say a little bit more
about that in a moment.
And beyond language
and text, we're
seeing emerging
applications on these TPUs
in speech recognition,
which you can find
in the Tensor2Tensor toolkit.
I'll say a bit more about that.
And if you're more
of a researcher,
you're interested in
generating images from scratch,
and some of these
far out applications
where these machine
learning models
are synthesizing new types
of imagery and sound,
you can do those on TPU too.
And we've got a great example
of an image transformer model.
So let me go through some
of these applications
and this variety of
applications in turn.
Image classification
typically are
focusing on small
crops of images
like you're seeing here, and
then applying a category.
This is useful for
everything from photo
sharing to medical imaging.
Object detection,
like I mentioned
before, you might
have a larger image,
like I'm showing here
off to the right.
And you want to detect
a bunch of items in it
and classify them
and apply labels
with different confidences.
In this case,
RetinaNet can operate
on surprisingly large
images, 896 by 896,
achieve a near state of
the art result pm COCO,
a standard object
recognition data set,
and you can get to
that level of accuracy
in about six hours for just
$40 on one of the Cloud TPUs
that you can rent today.
I think that's pretty exciting
for democratizing machine
learning and providing
a building block for you
to build your own
object detection
applications on top of.
In machine translation,
on the WMT data set
that translates
English to German,
we get to a blue score of 28.6
in just over six hours, again,
for around $40.
For language
modeling, as you might
use for an application
like Smart Reply,
where you're trying to predict
what words or phrases happen
next, it costs a little
bit more because you
have to train longer to get
to the state of the art,
but you reach the state of
the art in just 74 hours.
again, for under $500.
And this, for the
latest hyper-parameters,
I'd recommend following the
short link on screen now.
That takes you to the
Tensor2Tensor toolkit, which
is built on top of
TensorFlow, and is
moving even faster and really
keeping up with, or extending,
the state of the
art in research.
For speech recognition,
which you can also
find in Tensor2Tensor, you can
get to a word error rate of 7.9
in just 13 hours for $86.
Or you can train
longer to get even
closer to the state of the art
with a 7.3% word error rate.
And this is a really
great starting point
for processing large
volumes of audio
or training your robot to
listen to your voice commands
or anything else
you'd like to do.
I'd also like to
emphasize that even
techniques that you
wouldn't necessarily think
are a good fit for accelerators,
like question answering,
can be accelerated.
Here's a QANet where you
take in a paragraph of text,
some region of
unstructured text,
and you're asked a question
that has an answer in that text.
And this QANet will
highlight the fact
in this unstructured
blob of text
that corresponds to the answer.
This is a fast implementation
that won the DAWNBench SQuAD
challenge.
And so there's going to be
an open source implementation
of this coming soon.
Now, I mentioned image
generation earlier.
You can see off to the
right in these rows
of different
categories, these images
have actually been synthesized
from scratch using the image
transformer model.
And using a Cloud TPU, you can
get to a score of 2.98 bits per
dimension-- lower is
better in this case--
in 30 hours for under $200.
I've also provided
a link to the paper
here if you're interested
in learning more.
So I've mentioned this
variety of reference models,
and there are more
coming all the time.
I'd really encourage you--
even though it's tempting,
to take some older code and
try and port it to the TPU--
I'd really recommend starting
with one of these reference
models to experience the full
performance of the platform
right away.
And maybe even reach
higher accuracy,
since these models are so
close to the state of the art.
They're high performance,
they're open source,
they're cutting edge.
We continuously test them
for performance and accuracy,
even as all the versions
of underlying software
are evolving rapidly.
And they really let you
get up and running quickly.
And then, it's your code.
It's open source.
You can modify it as
you need and train
and run on your own data.
So I want to emphasize, though,
that you don't just have
to use these reference models.
You can build
models from scratch,
using layers and estimators,
and the TF data API.
And there's lots of
detailed technical advice
in this troubleshooting
guide and also
in our performance guide and
our documentation of help tools.
But we're really trying to
do the hardest work for you
via our reference models.
So definitely,
start there today.
Just to give you one quick
sense of why high performance
computing can be so
hard, when you're
using previous accelerators
that may not have been as fast,
it's easy to overlap your input
processing with your training.
And so then you're fully
utilizing your accelerators,
which are often the most
expensive part of the system.
But now, when the
accelerators get faster,
suddenly you're bottlenecked
on the input processing
and your accelerators are
idle, waiting for data.
It's quite challenging to build
these balanced systems that
can keep the fastest
accelerators supplied
with data all the time.
And so that's really
what we're trying
to do with our
TPU supercomputers
and also with all these software
layers that we build on top.
Fortunately, if you are
performance tuning one
of these models, we've
got these great tools
that are integrated
with TensorBoard
and available for Cloud TPUs.
The Cloud TPU profiler
lets you actually
get detailed op by op
statistics about how
your models are performing and
where they're bottlenecked.
And this is a
really amazing tool
to let you optimize
your own models
and get them running,
training at full potential.
We even try to give
you high level advice.
I don't know if you can
read it here in red.
But this is telling you
that your program is not
input bounded.
So keep working
on your step time.
We're really trying to provide
higher and higher level
guidance as you're optimizing
these models on the TPU.
So let me just say
for a moment why
we recommend doing machine
learning in the cloud--
how that's providing
advantages to you,
even if you're used to
working under your desk
or in an on premise data center.
Google Cloud provides
top notch infrastructure,
and you can mix and
match whatever components
that you need.
You can provision
quickly, you can scale up,
and then you can scale back
down as your needs change
and really burst to take
advantage of teraflops
or even petaflops of
machine learning compute.
We've also got a variety
of different accelerators.
We've got the best
of CPUs, GPUs, TPUs.
You can mix and
match those together
to get the right mix
for each workload
that's interesting to you.
We've got fantastic security,
world class security,
and powerful tools for
data access control
and controlling the way
that it's being used.
And most importantly, we
let you reduce your capital
expenditure.
Instead of having to
place orders for hardware,
wait for months, deploy
them, change the cooling
and power in your data
centers to support
these powerful
accelerators, you can just
use our on demand
pricing to pay only
for what you need, which we
find to be much more economical,
especially when your
workloads are unpredictable.
Just to give you two
examples of customers
who are using Cloud TPUs
today, both Two Sigma and Lyft
have found it really
convenient to be
able to move to the cloud, take
models that they already had,
in some cases, and accelerate
them, or take our reference
models and use them
to achieve new results
on their own internal data sets.
Now, I'll give you just a
brief glimpse under the hood
to give you a little bit more
detail on how these Cloud
TPUs are able to achieve
such amazing performance.
Now, I mentioned before
that each Cloud TPU
delivers 180 teraflops
of computation
with 64 gigabytes of memory.
And it's actually
got four chips, one
under each of those heat sinks.
And so here, in
just a minute, I'm
going to focus on
one of those chips.
But first, let me
explain that the Cloud
TPU is connected to a host,
behind the scenes, via PCI.
So you get the benefit
of both this host, where
some operations can
be placed, and then,
ideally, as much of the
computation as possible
is placed on the accelerator.
So let's zoom in on
one of these TPUs.
So the Cloud TPU chip is
divided into two cores,
as you can see here.
The chip as a whole
has 16 gigabytes
of HBM split between the cores.
And each core delivers
22 and 1/2 teraflops
and consists of a scalar unit,
a vector unit, and especially
this matrix unit, which is
really special and uniquely
suited for the demands of high
performance machine learning.
Now, focusing on
this matrix unit,
it's actually 128 by
128 systolic array.
Now, systolic arrays are this
old idea in chip architecture,
but they're newly
relevant now that we
have these deep learning models
that have many, many layers
and consist of many
matrix operations,
often on these
gigantic matrices.
One important fact
about our matrix unit
is that we're actually using
a different floating point
format, bfloat16
in the multiplies,
even though we're doing
float32 accumulate.
And that turns out to be
a great floating point
format for machine learning.
It's almost a drop in
replacement for Float32.
And yet it lets
us pack even more
compute into the same
amount of silicon area.
So let me tell you just a
little bit more about bfloat16.
So you may be used to
programming in float32.
That's what most
people use today,
for machine learning models.
And here's how those
32 bits are distributed
between the exponent
and the mantissa.
Now, IEEE float16 chops
both of those down.
So you have a much reduced
exponent and a much reduced
mantissa.
Bfloat16, by contrast,
actually uses a lot more bits
for the exponent, which lets
us represent numbers that still
have this full range, but you
lose a little bit of detail
in fine distinctions
between numbers.
Turns out, for all of
these state of the art
deep learning models, those
fine distinctions don't matter.
But the range matters a lot.
And so you get a much
simpler user experience
working with bfloat16 than you
do having to worry about fp16,
where you've got
to think carefully
about whether the numbers are
in the right ranges, everywhere
throughout your model.
And there are
complicated techniques
that you have to apply
on a model by model basis
to avoid your numbers exploding
or under flowing or all sorts
of numerical problems.
We reduce those problems a
lot by working with bfloat16
on the Cloud TPU.
So now here, I just
want to show you a three
by three toy example to
represent this 128 by 128
systolic array, to give you a
sense of how, as input data is
streaming through, there
can be a lot of reuse
of intermediate computations
inside the systolic array,
which gives this
fantastic throughput
for these large
matrix operations.
Now, I just want to
look ahead briefly
to give you a sense of where
we think the field is going,
and why these Cloud TPUs and TPU
pods are so well-suited to help
support the future of machine
learning products and research.
Now, these Cloud
TPU pods enable you
to train with very large batch
sizes, which you might wonder,
well, how does the scaling go as
you go beyond a single device?
Fortunately, we've got this
proprietary network that
connects all these devices
together in this mesh,
and we've been able to show near
perfect linear scaling out all
the way to the full scale
pod, as you can see here,
as the number of devices
increases to 64, which is
the full set in the TPUv2 pod.
Now, I mentioned large batches.
One other issue you have
to wonder about when you're
dealing with large
batch training
is whether you can still
make efficient progress
towards the ultimate goal.
Previously, as people increased
the batch size, at some point,
you would find that you wouldn't
reach the final accuracy
that you were expecting.
And so there was sort of a
mathematical limit in how large
you could make the batch
size before it was no longer
efficient or useful to do so.
But there's been a lot of
progress on this recently,
and there's still
very active research.
And what I'm showing here is
that a model that might take,
in that sort of golden curve,
many hours on a single board
to get to the 76% accuracy, as
you scale up within the pod,
just increasing the batch
size, not changing the code,
you can achieve
that same accuracy
in shorter and shorter
wall clock times, which
really lets you iterate faster.
Because remember, this is
like compiling your code.
Right?
You need to compile
your code many times
to iterate and explore.
And sometimes, if
you're doing something
like hyper-parameter tuning or
neural architectures search,
you want to train
hundreds or even
thousands of different models.
And on these pods, you can
really pull that time in
to get to the same accuracy,
and iterate much more quickly
and make faster progress.
Now, here's just a glimpse
of our future roadmap.
I mentioned the TPUv3 pod that
we announced at Google I/O.
And here's the full system
with these eight racks.
And the whole pod,
as I mentioned,
is more than eight times more
powerful than the TPU pod.
And actually, to get to
this level performance,
we brought liquid cooling
into our data centers
for the first time,
as you can see here
on one of the boards that makes
up that gigantic TPUv3 pod.
So we're really excited
about continuing
to expand the frontier
of machine learning.
You can get started
with Cloud TPUs today.
There's no waiting,
there's no sign up,
there's no need to
make a quota request.
Every GCP project can
start a Cloud TPU today.
And you can follow the
link at the bottom,
the g.co/cloudtpu
link to get started,
or one of these other links
to peruse the code of our open
source reference models, or jump
straight to our documentation.
With that, I'd
like to invite you
to stay tuned for live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Hi, everyone.
I'm back to answer your
questions about Cloud TPUs.
So one question here is,
I filed a quota request
and haven't heard back yet.
When will I get a chance
to try Cloud TPUs?
The good news is, as of
recently, you no longer
need to file a quota request.
Cloud TPU quota is
available to everyone.
So you can just go to
Google Cloud today,
and you should find quota
for at least two Cloud TPUs,
possibly more.
And you can start one up right
now in the US central region.
Let's see.
There's another
question here, asking
about the performance of TPUs
versus GPUs or other platforms.
Now, as I mentioned earlier, one
thing that we really recommend
is that you perform your
own benchmark measurements
on the workloads
that matter to you,
using ideally, our reference
models that give you
this great starting
point, but in any case,
we really emphasize that
you should benchmark
with realistic training
data, so you're
measuring the actual
accuracy along the way,
not just the samples per second.
And think about the
total time that it
takes to get to an
accuracy, if you're
measuring training,
or the throughput,
if you're measuring inference.
And also the total
cost on public clouds.
Or if you're working on premise,
the whole capex and opex
to run the machines
and maintain them,
to get a complete
picture of how to compare
one platform to another.
If you want to look at
TPUs and GPUs specifically,
one of our customers,
RiseML, has
published a series
of blog posts where
they've looked at TPU and GPU
performance quite carefully.
You can also look at the
Stanford DAWNBench results.
Let's see.
Where can I access
these reference models?
So in the TensorFlow
GitHub repository
at GitHub.com/tensorflow,
there's a directory slash TPU,
and a lot of our reference
models are in there.
As I mentioned during
the talk, though,
there are some of
these that are also
in a different repository, which
is called Tensor2Tensor, where
the two is a numeral,
and it's all one word.
So keep an eye on our
reference repository in GitHub,
and then also take a look
at the Tensor2Tensor library
for the real cutting edge of
these sequence to sequence
models.
This is a great question.
Can I do inference on
TPUs, or only training?
TPUs support both
training and inference.
At the moment, our software
stack is continuing to mature,
and I'd really recommend
training and batch inference.
Over time, as we continue to
optimize the software stack,
TPUs should be great for
low latency inference too,
but I would wait just a little
bit longer before diving
into that.
And now, somebody's asked--
well, wait, this is the
second generation of TPUs.
Is there a third generation?
And so, as I mentioned
through the talk,
we revealed the
third generation TPU
at Google I/O. It's liquid
cooled, we assemble them,
it's a whole new chip
in a whole new system
that we assemble into
much larger pods that
deliver more than 100 petaflops
of compute, collectively.
So we're pushing the frontier
forward, as far as we can,
to enable us to train
even larger and more
powerful and accurate machine
learning models that will then
benefit all the users
of Google products
through all our
different applications.
Let's see if there are
any other questions here.
Great.
So one other thing that
you might wonder about
is how to do interactive
development with these Cloud
TPUs.
And one thing that
I'd recommend would
be do as much as you can
with layers and estimators
and the data sets
API on a Cloud TPU
before you think about scaling
up into a slice of a pod.
So the experience that we're
really trying to build towards
is one where you
can inexpensively
treat one of these Cloud TPUs
as your personal supercomputer
in the cloud, that you can
just sit on-- instead of having
to worry about a
machine under your desk,
you just log into the
cloud and pay only
for what you're using as
you do your development.
And then when you're
really ready to scale up,
just by changing the batch
size, suddenly you're
able to transform days into
hours or hours into minutes
and get a lot more done
in a day than you used
to be able to do in a week.
So we're building a
whole new paradigm
for machine learning research,
development, and production
here with Cloud TPUs.
And we invite all of you
to join us on this journey
and try out Cloud TPUs today.
Thanks very much.
Stay tuned for the
next session, which is
Make Your Applications Fast and
Reliable with the Stackdriver
API.
Thanks again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]